the winner
to organize
the 222 FIFA World Cup is Qatar
smaller than Connecticut the tiny Gulf
State of Qatar is about to host the
world's biggest football tournament but
to pull off the most prestigious event
in International Football cutter has
opened itself to a deluge of negative
headlines a collective statement
criticizing qatar's human rights record
there have been concerns about how lgbtq
plus fans will be treated and is
estimated to have spent up to 300
billion US Dollars getting ready for
kickoff making it the most expensive
World Cup in history
sort of the the world's most expensive
bet on a football tournament so just why
has Qatar risked so much to host the
2022 World Cup
[Music]
the World Cup is an expensive
competition to host but accurate figures
on the exact costs of building
everything from stadiums to hotels are
difficult to come by
some sources estimate that Brazil spent
15 billion dollars in 2014. Russia spent
approximately between 12 billion and 15
billion dollars in 2018 and as of
November 2020 it is estimated Qatar has
spent as much as 300 billion dollars
making this the most expensive World Cup
ever
cutter hopes the cachet of hosting the
competition will help it make its mark
on the world stage
the World Cup I think has to be seen in
the context of attempts to kind of carve
out for a separate space in the region
that kind of gives it a sense of
prestige a sense of influence and you
know a sense of identity really in the
face of perhaps some of it's more more
powerful and assertive Neighbors
[Music]
FIFA estimates 5 billion fans will watch
the competition opening Qatar up to the
scrutiny of the world's media
[Music]
said more than 6 500 migrant workers
from India Pakistan Nepal Bangladesh and
Sri Lanka have died in Qatar we've seen
a few series of questions about how
inclusive the tournament will be
questions about environmental
sustainability questions about of course
migrant labor rights 27 year old Shiva
tamang died in a building site accident
on April the 19th I think a lot of those
things have also challenged other to
address a lot of the ways that it has
conducted its Affairs to understand why
the World Cup matters so much to Qatar
you have to understand its history and
its relationship with its Gulf Neighbors
with a population of Less Than 3 million
it began life with an Economy based on
Pearl diving but the oil boom of the
1950s led to Qatar becoming one of the
richest countries in the world per
capita
but oil came to the rescue of many
former Pearl divers the Shadows cast by
bigger golf neighbors and the imposition
of British rule until Independence in
1971 have made Qatar work hard to
establish itself on the world stage Papa
had a late start with development and
modernization and transforming the
country and it wasn't a catch-up sort of
a mindset it was surrounded by neighbors
who had started decades earlier had the
resources had the institutions had the
know-how and the experience
so much in the Gulf comes down to
personalities because these are
hereditary monarchies that are often
ruled for very long periods of time uh
by the same people and certainly by the
same family
when Qatar switch Focus from oil to
exploiting is ample natural gas Fields
it became one of the largest liquefied
natural gas exporters in the world and
per capita the wealthiest country in the
region but with the Fantastical wealth
created by the gulf's abundance of oil
and gas came huge competitiveness
all of these countries are trying to
avoid the curse of being just oil or gas
producers and nothing else other was
trying to distinguish itself from the
crowd by investing in sectors that were
different
but also making political choices that
were at times at odds with what
neighboring countries wanted or expect
or would normally tolerate having
phenomenal wealth in a country that has
the tiniest of populations means having
effectively unlimited resources to spend
on all sorts of projects meant to build
its Prestige around the world
we've seen a massive investment in
things like sports medicine facilities
and museums in universities as well as
education and culture and so there was a
sense that there was kind of a plan at
work three two one the next part of the
master plan was to take on the media
launching Al Jazeera enabled Qatar to
portray itself as a beacon of openness
in what many regard as a repressive
region
the CNN of the Arab world all of a
sudden there was a pan-arab network
bringing multiple perspectives
showcasing the internal debates within
Arab society and then of course bringing
coverage of things like the US invasion
of Afghanistan in Iraq or the
Palestinian tefada or of course later on
the Arab uprisings that emerged in 2010
and so Qatar being kind of at the
Forefront of that was in some ways a
recognition that it wanted to carve for
itself a distinct place in the region
that was not like that of its neighbors
for instance Iran or Saudi Arabia or the
United Arab Emirates
focusing the spotlight on its neighbors
raised tensions
but this was only the beginning of
qatar's ambitions
[Music]
in 2009 Qatar made its biggest play yet
bidding to hold the World Cup in a
country with just one fifa-regulated
stadium and a climate so hot the grass
requires its own air conditioning
baffled many
I think there was a lot of confusion
around the world not only about why this
small country had been given it but
whether it would be able to prepare you
know for the influx of a million fans
over the course of a month in a country
that at the time only had about 2
million people living in it but for
Qatar it was an obvious opportunity you
can think of the bid to host the World
Cup and the massive Investments made by
father in the last decade to organize
the tournament as a deliberate exercise
in economic diversification this is a
sector that you could invest in possibly
and that will pay off for you into the
future
since it won the bid to host the
transformation of the country has been
colossal eight new stadiums airport and
Road expansions hotels hospitals and a
Metro System have all been built to
accommodate this huge event
[Music]
a significant amount of money spent in
the organization of a tournament that in
the process brings about development
Prosperity progress and shapes the image
of the country in the eyes of the world
I think has been a good bet
but qatar's gamble to position itself as
a major player almost backfired with its
neighbors
when on June 5th 2017 Saudi Arabia UAE
Bahrain and Egypt cut all Land Air and
sea links to Qatar
the blockade was a shock to potteries
and it was a very formative event for so
many people living in the country it was
a surprise they sort of woke up one
morning and found that their land border
their only land border with Saudi Arabia
had been closed the gulf states that
were blockading got that at the time
were exhibiting a sense of resentment
toward the fact that Qatar had achieved
hosting duties for the World Cup this is
symbolic or representative of some of
the kind of deeper underlying issues and
rivalries that have existed in this
region for far longer than we've been
talking about the FIFA World Cup
the blockading Nations issue Qatar with
a list of 13 demands including ending
its alleged connections with terrorist
groups
all of them had to do with the country's
foreign policy and the fact that sort of
uniquely among the Gulf States it did
not share the foreign policy of Saudi
Arabia and the UAE the the two big
heavyweights of the region and so the
most obvious demand was a demand for
author to cease its support for groups
like the Muslim Brotherhood before
political islamist groups across the
region that have long been opposed to
Saudi and the UAE
the list also demanded Qatar sever ties
with Iran a known antagonist of Saudi
Arabia
but with so much of the country's wealth
tied up in the gas field it shares with
the ram the state had little choice but
to work around the blockade
cutter for new trade routes mainly with
turkey to redirect its Supply chains
in some ways a kind of unintended
consequence of the blockade was that it
actually made the region less integrated
and it made Potter far more
self-sufficient in a way given the fact
that it developed all of these other
mechanisms on January 5th 2021 three and
a half years after it started the
blockade abruptly ended despite Qatar
refusing to agree to any of the 13
demands when you ask people in the Gulf
why they decided to end the blockade
when they did last year you sort of hear
different answers one of them is that
some countries in the region came to a
recognition that this wasn't working it
exacted a huge diplomatic cost on them
as well in the west there were a lot of
countries that were upset about this and
wanted the gulf countries to mend fences
the World Cup was coming up and everyone
else in the Gulf stands to benefit from
the world cup from fans who might choose
to base themselves in places like Dubai
fans who might after going to matches
and Doha want to be a tourist and go
somewhere else in the region there was
an economic benefit to be had and the
gulf countries didn't want to lose out
on that benefit by maintaining the
blockade
whether the conflict between the Gulf
States will resume after the final
whistle blows is unclear
a lot of the underlying issues are still
very much present whether we're talking
about other major political disruptions
regionally whether having to do with
various other states in their region or
the kind of ongoing standoff with Iran
then of course some of these rivalries
might might continue to kind of play out
as they have before
but the fact that those countries are
now piggybacking on The Spoils of
hosting a World Cup suggest Qatar
already achieved some success they've
acted a bit like a football team with a
very wealthy owner who's willing to
throw a lot of money at taking a shot on
a star player not knowing exactly how
that player is going to work out but
being willing to make that effort with
sort of the the world's most expensive
bet on a football tournament if all goes
well the joys of the month-long
tournament will help Qatar build its
image as a global sporting Hub but the
criticisms it has faced mainly on human
rights aren't going away
hopefully even after the World Cup ends
and the world's attention shifts to
somewhere else that will not see a kind
of backslide from addressing these
issues in criticisms
with the world focusing on the hosts and
not just the football whether it's 300
billion dollar gamble will fully pay off
remains to be seen
it's a hard thing to say before the
tournament uh what sort of Legacy it
will be a lot of this depends on
questions like did they overbuild you
know all of these highways all of these
hotels everything that has been built
for this world cup doesn't find the use
maybe it won't next year but will it
find a use five years ten years hence
will this all look like sort of one
giant white elephant that maybe gave
everyone a good show for a month but
turned out to be tens of billions of
dollars of wasted money
from Father's perspective of course it
has been very much folded into the idea
of a kind of a massive National
modernization plan maintaining its
ability to not just Host this tournament
but going forward to there's been talk
of a future Olympic Bid And so there's a
sense that but that is now known in a
way that it certainly wasn't uh 10 or 12
years ago
I'm Greg carlstrom The Economist Middle
East correspondent to read more of our
coverage of the World Cup and Qatar
click the link and don't forget to
subscribe
foreign